foreign
[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and tonight we get episode 5 of Marvel's
secret Invasion and we just got a
special clip released by Marvel Studios
and it has us wondering is Nick Fury's
wife going to die in secret invasion is
Nick Fury going to die in secret
Invasion yes we have seen him in the
trailer for the Marvels however they
could simply do a flashback or a jump
forward in time and Marvel Studios with
secret Invasion has been killing off
some characters that we've known for a
very long time I fortunately think that
Nick Fury is probably safe however I do
think his wife is most likely going to
die graphic has a tendency to
specifically Target people who are very
close to Nick Fury people that he cares
about more than anything and graphic has
done this on purpose not trying to kill
him but trying to make him suffer gravic
has had every opportunity to kill Nick
Fury but he never does instead when he
gets the opportunity to kill somebody
that means a great deal to Nick Fury he
takes that opportunity without
hesitation and I think what we're seeing
here in this clip is gravic and as men
going after Nick Fury's wife Priscilla
the beginning of this scene shows Gaia
and Nick Fury's wife Priscilla at the
home of the Furious it looks like
they're in the kitchen at the dining
room table and then all of a sudden they
start getting shot at but this is Nick
Fury's home and this is Nick Fury's wife
so naturally there are preparations in
place plus not to mention you know
Priscilla is actually a scroll spy so
she might even have measures in place
that Fury doesn't even know about but
Priscilla and Gaia run to another room
where she opens up a drawer that has two
bags in it now she gives one to Gaia and
puts one on herself however we can
assume that one of these bags the one
that she gives the Gaia was meant for
Fury himself this is most likely the two
Escape bags that the couple prepared for
themselves in case anybody ever came
after Nick Fury now as Priscilla and
Gaia go to put these backpacks on and
equip themselves with some guns we
actually see the men come in we see them
shooting up the house and in the
background we can see that Priscilla was
busy we see that she was doing work we
can see plants everywhere we can see
containers filled with different types
of soil in the background and throughout
this show we have seen that the scroll
have been able to actually farm and
produce scroll plants from scrollos and
they've been able to make some of the
food that they had on their home and
this could be something that Priscilla
was trying to do as well keep in mind
Nick Fury knew that she was a scroll and
Nick Fury had been gone for many many
years he was up on saber so Priscilla
probably started to do her scroll thing
and we know that she is just like the
other scroll she wants a home for
herself so she's contributing to that
and trying to help with vegetation with
plants Etc now the men that come in do
most likely belong to ravik and at this
point in time they are going to be after
both Gaia and Priscilla in the last
episode Priscilla Vara her scroll name
met with Rody who we found out was
indeed like we predicted the entire time
a scroll at the end of the last
episode's credits they have this scroll
who turned into Roadie in the episode
listed as rabba and rava ordered
Priscilla or Vara to kill Nick Fury but
Priscilla did not do that in a nice
loving scene we found out that Priscilla
does actually love Nick Fury and despite
everything Nick Fury does love her as
well but this now puts a Target on
Priscilla's back and now Priscilla slash
Vara has technically betrayed the scroll
rebellion and gravic plus on Dimension
graphic is probably tracking Gaia so
there's a pretty good chance that gravic
had tracked Gaia to Fury's house and
realized that he could Now kill two
birds with one stone possibly even three
if Nick Fury was there but no doubt
killing Gaia and Priscilla was his plan
and like I mentioned before he probably
doesn't even want to kill Fury at this
point in time he probably wants Fury to
suffer even more and watch his home and
his species become extinct he's not done
making Furies suffer yet and he wants to
make him suffer because Fury never held
out on his promise to find the scroll a
new home so the team comes in shooting
up the entire place and we see a really
really cool fight scene with some really
cool details in here the backpacks that
they throw on have some really cool gun
holstering properties that make it very
accessible to not only equip the gun but
also put it back up we see Priscilla
take the gun out of the front part of
the bag Gaia takes one out of the
shoulder and we both see how convenient
it is for them to reload as all of the
ammo is kept in a very convenient place
that of course is very strategic it's
really cool to see this attention to
detail especially them actually
reloading the bullets in fact Amelia
Clarke's Gaia puts off a very big John
Wick Vibe here and it's a great scene
that shows that these two characters
right here are very capable of handling
themselves showing that they are two
very powerful characters and hopefully
Emilia Clarke's Gaia is going to stick
around in the MCU for some time now so
this is really setting her up as a very
capable character not only does she seem
to be combat trained but she's also a
super scroll down and we can assume that
graphic probably isn't going to survive
this show so she would be the only super
scroll if her and graphic are the only
ones who went through this procedure
through the machine that they have so
just like the MCU instead of having the
scroll be bad made them good with their
first debut perhaps we could have a good
super scroll in the MCU from here on out
however like I mentioned I'm not sure
Fury gets his happy ending because now
gravic and his men are after his wife
and not to mention the US government is
probably after her as well now because
Roadie or rava told Priscilla to kill
Nick Fury or he's gonna kill her so he
could have made up whatever is necessary
to send the Secret Service or some type
of people Hitman after Priscilla the
question is now is graphic going to take
it upon himself personally to see that
Nick Fury suffers even more it's
definitely going to be infuriating to
graphic to see somebody who he thought
would never betray him who was on his
side someone who was like a mother to
him because remember Bara is the one who
brought gravic to Fury we saw that in
the beginning of episode 2 showing us
the connection between Vara and gravic
and of course that connection with Fury
she meant a lot to gravic and now he's
going to feel betrayed by her so he
might make it a point to not only kill
her for himself but to kill her to make
Fury suffer even more and so far he's
been pretty successful at doing that
spoiler alert if you haven't seen any of
the other episodes but he killed Maria
Hill and he just killed Talos at least
so we think he did one of the great
things about this series is you don't
really know what's real or not but let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below do you think
Priscilla slash Vara is going to make it
out alive and Nick Fury gets his happy
ending or do you think gravic is going
to kill her leave your comments down
below also don't forget to like this
video And subscribe and leave a comment
so you can stay up to date on the MCU
and enter a giveaway for a chance to win
an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month you can
also support us on patreon you can check
out our website and our Discord server
and you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter we'll link all those down below
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign